oui il ya déjà un peu de monde qui
empruntent les transports en commun les
l'heure de pointe vous l'avez dit c'est
maintenant en tout cas c'est en train
d'arriver
est ce qu'on constate immédiatement
c'est que l'immense majorité pour ne pas
dire la quasi totalité des passagers
portent un masque il faut dire que le
port du masque est désormais obligatoire
dans les transports en commun il s'agit
ce matin en fait d'un test grandeur
nature pour ce qui compte ce qui est
considéré pour beaucoup comme un point
d'inquiétude en tout cas pour les
passagers emprunter les transports en
commun c'est une source d'inquiétude
pour eux alors la ratp assure pouvoir
assurer 75 % de ses capacités mais ne
peut accueillir que 15 % du trafic
habituel et ce en raison des règles de
distanciation sociales qui ont été mises
en place que ce soit dans les couloirs
du métro ou dans les rames du métro ou
encore dans les bus alors il a été
demandé aux entreprises de poursuivre le
télétravail dans la mesure du possible
et quand cela n'est pas possible il
s'agit pour eux peut-être d'étaler les
heures d'embauché de sortie du travail
l'idée vous l'avez compris c'est de ne
pas engorger les transports en commun en
mettant tout le monde dans les
transports en commun à la même heure
alors il ya donc ces règles de
distanciation sociales qui ont été mises
en place dans les transports en commun
on imagine qu'elles vont être assez
difficile à respecter il a également été
demandé aux passagers de respecter les
gestes barrières et donc le port du
masque obligatoire
initialement les passagers qui devaient
emprunter les transports en commun entre
6h30 ce matin et 9h30 devait être en
possession d'une attestation d'employeur
pour justifier leurs déplacements mais
vous l'avez dit la loi promulguant
l'état d'urgence sanitaire n'a pas été
promulguée à temps et donc cette mesure
a été remise à plus tard et toute façon
il y avait une sorte de laisser aller
pour les premiers jours de ce déconfit
demandant
l'autre cas le gouvernement en appelle
au civisme et à la responsabilité de
chacun en tout cas vous l'avez dit donc
3000 agents ratp ont été mobilisés ainsi
que des forces de l'ordre pour faire
respecter toutes ces consignes pour le
déconfinement on va essayer de vous
montrer ce matin ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de cette gare saint-lazare
mais pour nous aussi vous l'imaginez il
faut respecter des règles de
distanciation social on essaiera quand
même de vous montrer ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur